how's cumbrous my name is today we're
gonna play agario it's a game about
eating or get eaten alive
I was pretty doing well last time so I
think I'm gonna do yeah I'll do okay I
guess life's flight someone wrote in
Danish your mom is dead number four the
more to do it it's still horrible okay
let's think of a funny and witty name
okay there you go that's our name
burning pooper go burning pooper okay
burning pooper is alive
burning pooper is going this is the time
where we would take over this server
Belgium Belgium gotta destroy [ __ ] kill
Belgium and if there's any Belgium bros
please enjoy being inside my belly rich
Japan come here [ __ ] no [ __ ] eat you
you're little bit hochi atch yeah I'm
gonna eat you too come here Japan you're
not worth it Japan you're not worth it
ah Japan what the [ __ ] happened [ __ ] mr.
Kitz
brah no why did I do that that was a
terrible idea go back together
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] let's have
their raise fetuses this is a snack this
is a snack that I can eat yeah go to
Bulgaria you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] it's not there
you go baby suck yourself but a merry
little Christmas let yours that's not
not the lyrics boy yeah mm-hmm get him
damn it I sucked myself up for you
Oh [ __ ] got destroyed Wow
that's what I'm doing that's what I'm
talking about yeah yeah this is actually
pretty efficient way to grow quick oh my
god
but a Belgium is getting strong again
[ __ ] you Braille hey Belgium hey Belgium
we have a [ __ ] - burning poopa you want
a burning poop off your ass Belgium come
in burning for our you sneaky
[ __ ] [ __ ] well guess what Joe
can play that game [ __ ] Wow Pelham John
destroyed twice oh yes this is the best
round I ever had in my life
we're doing amazing I'll never I'll
never die oh I ate someone well you guys
are gonna get [ __ ] in the corner
aren't you
burning poop is only as strong as its
weakest link
Oh God oh good suck yourself up burning
poker quick quick Barney pooper whoa
come here dawn come on whatever I don't
know your name I don't need to Oh
get rag [ __ ] yeah that's how we do wit
that's how I'm talking about I love me
some burnin I'm tempted to kill Finland
there it is burnin poof up Oh
oh my god why am I so [ __ ]
slow-burning pooper assemble goddamnit
oh [ __ ] that was tighter than a your
mom's [ __ ] why are they not sucking
each other off I don't understand
burning puppies [ __ ] ten [ __ ] man I'm
[ __ ] amazing man get together man oh
oh oh
burning pooper so that's you just shake
your titties together how did I do that
that was amazing
Burnie pooper do it again do it again
Burnie pooper yeah burning pooper
assemble girls bet you didn't wanna [ __ ]
with the burning pooper [ __ ] didn't
what the [ __ ] just happened
burning poop will quick burning Papa
let's shine quickly out here go together
Burnie pooper oh that's right you want
to eat me you want to eat me put that
[ __ ] you up now believe it why [ __ ] out
alright breads hope you enjoyed this
video if you did go ahead and leave a
like it helps the show out a lot and I
really appreciate it
live comment about your burning pooper
experiences and I will see Bruce in the
next one that's always stay awesome